people who question the results of our
presidential elections are
insurrectionist terrorists and they pose
an existential threat to our democracy
they need to be censored ostracized and
possibly well actually probably thrown
in prison
unless and this is a very important
exception here
unless they are democrats who have been
denying and questioning the results of
our elections for decades and they
continue to do so and even today some
very prominent democrats can't admit
that they lost the presidential election
in two thousand
going back to two that uh to two
thousand do you think republicans stole
that election in 2000 i wish the united
states supreme court had let them finish
counting the votes
someone arrest that man so the that
former governor of virginia and current
candidate for governor of virginia terry
mcauliffe he is threatening
our democracy
and he is not the only one i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from the shuckmeister
who says between the degradation of
columbus day and the casting of chris
pratt as mario in the mario movie
anti-italian discrimination is running
rampant i couldn't possibly agree more i
even saw somewhere i don't know if this
was real or not but i think it was a
real statement that when chris pratt was
asked if he was going to speak in a
mario italian accent he said no he was
going to speak normal speak normal how
dare you sir
this is anti-italian discrimination
when you want to protect yourself your
culture more importantly though your
identity and your data i would recommend
you check out lifelock you know about
hardware you know what hardware is right
and you know about software you know
what software you've heard about these
things for a long time do you know about
bloatware
you probably haven't heard i had not
heard of this until lifelock told me
about it bloatware is software that is
pre-loaded on a new device that you
never asked for and could be potentially
harmful and slow your device down or
even put your personal information at
risk if you find bloatware on your
device be sure to uninstall it it's very
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives lifelock helps detect a wide range
of identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton i know what
you're thinking no one's coming after my
data michael no one's coming after my
stuff it's only just famous people and
powerful it's not true they're coming
after your stuff right now protect it
join now save up to 25 off your first
year by going to lifelock.com knowles
can wles that's lifelock.com knowles
canada wles for 25
off
the people who in any way raise any
doubts about the integrity of our
elections even when the democrats get
rid of all the election integrity
measures people who do that
are
insurrectionists get you got to remember
that because that's the line that the
media and the ruling class is going to
drill into your heads uh through big
tech through the media through the
politicians they're insurrectionist
terror they're no different than al
qaeda they just happen to be wearing
suits according to adam schiff
in the days after when the the the
trauma for a lot of us became even
greater
i was most angry at these
insurrectionists and suits and ties
these colleagues of mine who knew
it was a lie because a lot of the people
attacking that capital believed the lie
but the people i work with george and i
get asked about this all the time do the
republican members really believe what
they're saying
they know
uh it's a lie they know the election
wasn't rigged it wasn't stolen
but they just don't have the guts to
speak the truth and to me that's
unforgivable they know it's a lie they
know it's adam's very reasonable adam
schiff
one of the leading voices on the
well on the impeachment against donald
trump but also on the real insurrection
because he was a conduit for the deep
state that was trying to subvert trump
the entire time
the real insurrectionists uh are a
little hard to identify aren't they it
seems like there's a little projection
going on but this is a he makes a
specific claim here that i want to
address because it's extremely annoying
to me which is that look all the
republicans know this election was
absolutely above board it was totally
the most uh
obviously clear defendable uh
presidential election in history uh the
result was never more obvious and if you
question that you're you're just
a liar you're dishonest you're deceiving
people
there's no evidence whatsoever that the
democrats rigged the election
there is no question that the democrats
rigged the election okay i'll get to
whether or not they stole the election
in a minute but
it is absolutely incontrovertible that
the democrats rigged the election
because they changed all the rules right
before the election and in some cases
the way they changed the rules to give
themselves an advantage was not only
illegal but unconstitutional notably the
way that the election was conducted in
pennsylvania with the use of widespread
mail and ballots which violates the
state's constitution but a lot of other
election integrity measures that went by
the wayside show very clearly that the
election was rigged
it was now being conducted in such a way
with far more days to vote with the use
of widespread mail and ballots when
democrats are far better at voter
harvesting than republicans are it was
so clear that it was rigged now did that
steal the election
i mean this is
impossible to prove because you can't go
back in time but
had the election
been conducted
uh in the normal way would trump have
won i i don't know i don't nobody knows
that so i guess you can't say one way or
the other that it was stolen but it
absolutely was
rigged and to point that out does not
make you a terrorist or anything like
that it makes you a reasonable person
and by the way democrats still haven't
conceded the 2016 election and by the
way as terry mcauliffe shows they still
haven't conceded the 2000 election so
spare me
the pearl clutching and the crocodile
tears about our democracy give me a
break hillary clinton the last
democratic presidential candidate to
lose
or at least not not to make it to the
white house she won't admit that she
lost she will will continue to go on
morning shows and say that though it was
the russians it was the macedonians it
was this it was that
any way to avoid admitting that she lost
the election fair and square and she
says by the way she's not going to stay
out of politics because
of course our democracy is at stake
any interest at all in getting back into
the game of politics i will never be out
of the game of politics i'm not going to
be running for anything but i really
feel amy and i know
george was interviewing adam schiff
before
i really feel like our democracy is at
stake and there's many reasons for that
some of them we saw on
uh the screen with the insurrection some
of them because of the revelations about
facebook that creates a world of
disinformation instead of you know one
that we can agree on what the facts are
i really am worried about what's
happening at home and around the world
so i'm never gonna get out of uh you
know being uh involved worried and
hopefully trying to help in some way the
thing to remember when the left refers
to democracy they are always talking
about liberalism and those are
related concepts but they're different
democracy is just when the people rule
liberalism is the specific ideology that
comes out of the enlightenment and has
taken a particular course over the
centuries
sometimes the people can vote against
liberalism and when that happened like
notably when they voted for donald trump
when that happens
then the left calls that a threat to our
democracy but it's not it's manifestly
not a threat to our democracy it is
however a threat to liberalism and even
more specifically
it's a threat to their oligarchy the
liberal ruling class is increasingly
ruling as an oligarchy and so you'll
notice when hillary clinton says
facebook is a threat to our democracy
she's not saying it's a threat to our
democracy because a handful of people
control the flow of speech around a
republic that's the actual threat she
says it's a threat to our democracy
because they allow conservatives to
spread their own views which she calls
disinformation
so she says the threat to our democracy
is the fact that more people get to
speak
what she would prefer is for the
oligarchy to clamp down even
more
it's a threat to our democracy when
trump questions the election it's a
defense of our democracy when she
questions the election
that's what's going
on here
and the gop needs to stop playing into
it i don't want to hear another peep
about january 6th
the worst
day our democracy
so there have been many attacks on the
capital in our nation's history bombs
have gone off and not even that many
decades ago there have been attacks on
lawmakers
not only was the
january 6th whatever it was not the
greatest attack on our nation's capital
since 1812 it it wasn't even the
greatest attack on our democracy
of that year
right the blm riots were a far greater
deadlier more dangerous attack on our
democracy they attacked a federal
courthouse they attacked police stations
they killed dozens of people they
attacked private businesses they they
attacked private residences
that was a far greater attack on our
democracy and the squishes play along
so trump just sent out a very important
message a couple days ago to the family
of ashley babbitt don't forget the only
person who was killed in the political
violence of january 6th was a trump
supporter
initially we were told by the lying
media that a cop was killed by an
insurrectionist with a fire extinguisher
was complete lie completely made up the
only person who was killed in the
political violence was ashley babbitt
one of the trump supporters unarmed who
was shot
presumably by a capital police officer
she was an air force veteran she served
her country
did she really pose this grave threat to
anyone in that building or to our
democracy it seems a little dubious
there aren't really any investigations
no serious public investigations that
have gone into it and trump sent a
message to her family on ashley
babbitt's birthday today would have been
her birthday happy birthday ashley happy
birthday
we're looking at you and you're looking
down on your family and on us
my heart and the hearts of millions of
americans across the country are with
everyone
everyone who knew and loved her i
especially want to express my great
sympathy to
ashley's loving husband aaron and her
wonderful mother mickey
i spoke to both of them these are great
people
together we grieve her
terrible loss
there was no reason ashley should have
lost her life that day
we must all demand justice for ashley
and her family
so on this solemn occasion as we
celebrate her life
we renew our call for a fair and
nonpartisan investigation
into the death of ashley babbitt
just asking for an investigation george
floyd a career criminal who robbed a
pregnant woman at gunpoint who was
killed resisting arrest over a long
period of time while being arrested
committing a crime
he is killed
months and months long investigations
nationwide worldwide riots and the cop
who did it goes to prison convicted of
murder ashley babbitt a an air force
veteran who lived a good upstanding life
is killed
potentially committing a crime
potentially not committing a crime in
this this
riot at the capitol but which was she
armed was she actually posing a threat
she gets killed by a cop and everyone
celebrates does that seem fair does that
seem right to you that seems a little
disordered not so much as one major
investigation and what trump is calling
for is hey let's let's put the focus on
here let's see what's going on here
instead of always being on the defensive
and always buying into the left-wing
narrative you know when you want to not
only save your country but when you want
to save a little bit of money at the gas
tank i would strongly recommend you
check out
get upside gas prices are insanely high
right now i don't need to tell you that
i'm sure you've noticed it well i'm
thrilled to introduce to you an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside
my listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every gallon of gas every time they
fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code knowles
and get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on
your first fill up that's up to 50 cents
cash back do not pay full price at the
pump anymore get cash back using get
upside down load the app for free and
use promo code knowles canon wles to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back
there's no catch the cash back gets
added right to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free getupside
app and use promo code nolskwles to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback on
your first tank that's code nulls
the squishes
are in many ways worse than the libs
you know the squishy
conservatives who always run away from
the conservative arguments and they they
like to suck up to the left-wing
establishment and they say i'm a
conservative but i'm not that kind of
conservative no don't i'm not like trump
i'm not like sarah palin i'm not like
ted cruz i'm not like this i'm not like
that they are we're a little harsh on
them
on this show but i think justly so they
are often worse
than the libs
okay i'll give you an example
new york times here we go
guest essay from miles taylor he was
that
he was a whistleblower in the trump
white house he was some underling in the
trump white house who who spent all of
his time trying to undermine the duly
elected president because this jerk felt
that he was much more important and had
much more authority than the man who was
elected by the american people
miles taylor and christine todd whitman
who is a very very liberal
republican governor of new jersey in the
90s it was a very long time ago and she
hasn't really mattered very much since
headline we are republicans there's only
one way to save our party from the
pro-trump extremists
the way this was was headlined on the on
the internet was we are republicans
and we're republicans for electing
democrats in 2022. we've this is very
important we've got to do it the only
way to save the party is to elect
democrats
okay
how many times are they going to run
this column
they run this column every election
cycle and they find a couple of squishes
and they say look we're republicans okay
but
whoa what's happened with trump is
unacceptable and uh before that what's
happened with the tea party is
unacceptable and before that what's
happened with the gingrich revolution
it's unacceptable and before that what's
happened we're republicans but this
ronald reagan character is unacceptable
and before that we're republicans but
this barry goldwater it's the same
freaking story every cycle and gullible
fools
believe it they buy into it
it's oh gosh you're right this this is
really scary those tea party people want
to cut taxes and spending that's a
threat to our democracy no we
this uh
this ronald reagan guy he wants to win
the cold war oh no that's a threat we
can't we can't oh and they every time
they call all these people nazis they
did it to goldwater they did it to
reagan they did it to buckley they did
it too
everyone is part of that uh conservative
movement they did it to trump they're
going to do it to the next guy too
they're doing it to desantis right now
so
they keep saying you know
this this one is a bit too far
it's really frustrating because
the role of these people
is to prop up the dominant liberal
establishment okay this is why i say the
squishes are worse than the libs when i
look at a lib i know what i'm dealing
with the lib can be honest that lib
could come to his opinions honestly and
might have a vision for the country that
is not my vision for the country and i
want to stop it but at least we know
what we're talking about
with the squishes there's such duplicity
there is such dishonesty and when
they're not dishonest and duplicitous
they're they're just cowardly
they just don't they don't either
they genuinely
believe that the only thing that matters
is cutting taxes a little bit which
means they're just greedy democrats
or
they just don't have the courage they
don't have the
spinal fortitude or maybe some other
anatomical fortitude to stand up to the
dominant liberal regime all they want
are plaudits from their opponents and
it's so
pathetic and it's so
counterproductive and i just wish that
they would become democrat i mean they
are democrats they're effectively
democrats
but
but they're not even honest about it i
mean there are people the never trump
movement
still exists and they're still they're
campaigning right now to elect democrats
in the midterms trump's not on the
ballot
trump is no longer the president but
they still they say oh the but the
trumpet was so bad we need to keep
electing democrats trump's going to be
dead 50 years they're going to say we
got to keep just to make sure that
there's no more trump we got to keep
electing democrats we're republicans for
democrats
whatever that means you've got to stand
up one guy who's not a squish
there are a handful of guys in this
party who are not squishes
but one guy who's definitely not a
squish ron desantis
you remember ron desantis voted to ban
mask mandates at the school level in
florida i thought this was great and the
squishes wailed and screamed and they
said this is a violation of liberty that
that now mean old ron desantis is using
his political power to stop school
boards from using their political power
to muzzle up students
and so that's a liberty true
true liberty suggests that we need to
just muzzle ourselves forever and you
think okay something's going wrong with
your definition of liberty folks but
desantis is going further he's not just
issuing this rule that the schools can't
mandate the masks
he's
taking
action because some schools are
violating his order we talked about this
yesterday with the texas pro-life law
it's not enough
just to pass a law and say okay we're
good we got the laws on the books now
we're good because what the libs are
going to try to do is not enforce the
law they're going to try to undermine it
at the executive level or at the
judicial level
where they're going to try to come in
and use a judge to upend it or they just
won't enforce it in the first place
so ron desantis is now defunding school
districts that are violating his mass
mandate ban
the florida board of education has voted
to sanction eight school districts
the penalty here will be defunding these
schools in an amount equal to one
twelfth of all school board members
salaries in addition to withholding any
equal amount to federal grant funds
awarded to those districts by the biden
administration good stuff enforce it
give it teeth i'm sick and tired of
pointless hearings and pointless
speeches and pointless orders and
pointless laws that don't actually have
teeth enforce it defund these people
wield your political power make sure it
sticks it's the only thing that will
matter
in politics if you if you
issue a bunch of orders or make a bunch
of laws but you don't enforce them then
you're just a think tank
and and a dis at least a you know a
think tank exists to to do that and then
they hand over their ideas to
politicians and the politicians are
supposed to enforce it if the
politicians
are not enforcing it then they are
completely abandoning
their duty okay
ron desantis obviously wants to be
president he's campaigning
he's setting the stage to campaign for
president he's doing a very good job of
it speaking of people who want to be
president though
we should turn to the other party to
kamala harris who just put out
one of the
most cringe inducing videos
i have ever seen i'll set the stage for
you it's kamala harris speaking to
students
about science
and the purpose of this is to show how
caring she is and broad-minded and
inspirational she is and i'll tell you i
did not know that this degree of
vapidity
could
exist but here we are
i just love the idea of exploring the
unknown
and then there's other things that we
just haven't figured out or discovered
yet to think about so much that's out
there that we still have to learn
like i love that i love that and so i'm
very excited about the space council
we're going to learn so much
as we increasingly i think are curious
and interested in the potential for
the discoveries and the work we can do
in space so
that's one of the things i'm most
excited about
but the other
you guys are gonna see you're gonna
literally see the craters on the moon
with your own eyes
with your own eyes i'm telling you it is
gonna be
unbelievable
has there ever been
a faker person
in
politics
america
the human race has there ever been
someone who seems less genuine and
authentic then kamala harris well it
gets even better because i'm looking at
this scene and they're on this porch and
they're all sitting and kamala harris is
pretending to be inspiring and she's
just
spouting out at gibberish and
and the world is big and wow you know
and uh but then i find out these aren't
even really just students it's not like
she's visiting some school or something
they're actors they're child actors
there was a casting call they had to
audition to be in this video so
everything about this is fake and
and inauthentic
the reason i even bring it up is because
joe biden's not looking so healthy not
looking like he's got a ton of energy
there's a good chance that kamala harris
is the nominee in in 2024
and there's
a good chance there's a good chance that
she becomes president even joe biden has
said as much
and
kamala harris is an old style of
politician politicians used to do
similar things to this they would even
reagan to some degree they they would
speak in a way that seemed scripted they
would they would speak in a way that was
just
very bland and and very uh
uh uncontroversial you know trump
completely upended that but but this is
the old style of politician and i just
wonder in a post-trump world if that's
if that's sustainable you know it just
seems like kamala harris is a is a woman
out of time she doesn't she doesn't seem
to know what time it is even sleepy joe
biden gets fired up and yells at trump
and calls him a racist and he's kind of
weird at least but kamala harris is just
so
stiff
and scripted and fake i i don't know
that that translates into the post-trump
era internet era and new media kind of
politics that we live in now speaking of
big shows
tonight we've got a really big a really
big show to quote ed sullivan a really
big backstage show instead of the usual
daily wire studio we're going to be live
streaming our conversation on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium right here
in nashville this is going to be an
event and a live stream unlike any other
that we've ever done and we're thrilled
to be able to share it with you
we're going to be making some extremely
exciting announcements which you're not
going to want to miss so be sure to tune
in join me ben shapiro candace owens
jeremy boring matt walsh andrew clavin
and our live audience for a backstage
like never before the live stream will
begin at 8 30 eastern 7 30 central head
on over to dailywire.com or the daily
wire youtube channel to catch the show
we'll be right back with a lot more
we've got an update from the cancel
culture this one i did not see coming
sir lawrence olivier
one of the
most celebrated actors from the 20th
century died many decades ago
sir lawrence olivier has been canceled
um
and actually not only has he been
canceled but a professor who played his
performance of othello a wonderful movie
in his class has also been canceled
breit shang who's the leonard bernstein
distinguished university professor of
composition at the university of
michigan school of music theater and
dance played the
1965 movie othello
featuring the great lawrence olivier but
if you know anything about othello
you'll know that laurence olivia's
darkened his skin he's wearing blackface
in the movie he's not doing blackface
like he's performing on a minstrel show
he's performing othello for goodness
sakes
and this
this really really bothered some
freshman chick so
you have lawrence olivier one of the
greatest actors of all time you have
othello one of the greatest plays of all
time and you have this professor breit
shang who's apparently a very very
distinguished professor at this
prestigious school of music
then you have this know-nothing freshman
girl and this no-nothing freshman girl
named olivia cook says quote i was
stunned
in such a school that preaches diversity
and making sure that they understand the
history of poc that's people of color in
america i was shocked that the professor
would show something like this in
something that's supposed to be a safe
space
so this girl who knows
nothing this is a very uneducated and
apparently very unintelligent person
is horrified to watch a very good movie
with a very good actor written by
probably the greatest playwright in the
english language she hates the fact that
she might have to learn something and
expand her mind and become educated so
she complains about this and she says
it's shakespeare's racist shakespeare
olivier is racist everybody this is
if you're racist
everything's racist and racism is the
worst thing in the world so
you got to cancel it
so you would hope
that at a serious educa educational
institution the administrators would say
hey lady shut up and sit in class and
learn that's what you're here for learn
but
we don't have serious educational
institutions anymore so the dean of the
school
sends out an email
not defending
shakespeare not defending lawrence
olivier not defending the professor as
he should but saying what professor
shang's actions do not align with our
school's commitment to
anti-racist action diversity equity and
inclusion all hail diversity inclusion
and equity the die ideology all hail it
he didn't say that i added i was
inferring that i was reading between the
lines
uh he says that shang has been reported
to the office of equity civil rights and
title ix over the incident
how dare he
expose the students
to shakespeare these people are
barbarians they're barbarians the
dean of this school is a barbarian he's
a deeply uncultured
uneducated person this
girl this freshman girl is obviously a
barbarian she is uneducated she is
uncultured but you know she gets a
little more leeway
the reason she's
at school right now is ostensibly to
stop being a barbarian
kids are barbarians okay
kids are uncultured kids are uneducated
by definition that's why we educate them
to bring them into culture and
civilization that's what she's there for
and so i don't even really blame her
what if she didn't know anything
her professors i guess this professor
was trying to educate her and give her
exposure to some culture but she's being
failed by the deans
and the administrators and the
universities
who
double down on her ignorance
and who punish people who attempt to
educate her this is what is happening
this is what my friend spencer clavin
has an excellent podcast it's called
young heretics where he just go he's an
oxford classicist and he goes over the
the great works in history and it's not
particularly political he just says
here's the liberal education that you
were denied okay and that increasingly
is happening even at top schools people
are not being given a proper education
and as that happens our society is going
to get coarser and dumber and less
cultured and more barbaric and we're all
going to be screaming and grunting and
clubbing each other over the head that
that is the normal state of savage
societies it's not the state of
civilization but increasingly we're
seeing civilization crumble around us
and they very often they use race as the
cudgel here because race has always been
a bit of a fault line in american
history but they would they would use
whatever they can they'd use sex if they
can they would use class if they can
they would use socioeconomic status they
would use whatever they can because the
goal here is is not to effect some great
sexual uh end or racial end or whatever
it's really just to destroy the
civilization
speaking of racial politics there's
breaking news this is breaking this is
headline news federal prosecutors
announced they will not file charges
against a white police officer who shot
jacob blake in wisconsin in 2020. you'll
remember jacob blake who is a black guy
it's very important apparently that he's
a black guy he was shot because he had
the cops called on him he was apparently
allegedly
sexually assaulting this woman and then
going out and taking her kid and driving
the kid away in a car and he also had a
weapon in his car and so the cops after
doing everything they could to stop this
guy peaceably they finally shot him and
the shocking headline that's a surprised
everybody is that they're not going to
punish the cop
why is this news
why is
this should
be obvious this is not a man by its dog
story the only troubling news is that
this is news the only troubling news is
that people expected that the cop would
be charged jacob blake survived the
shooting he's i think he's paralyzed or
something jacob blake got off easy jacob
blake
did not deserve to walk out of that
situation alive resisting arrest
allegedly assaulting a woman getting
into a car with weapons with a child in
there that he's going to drive away that
guy
got off real lucky okay and this cop who
shot him should be given an award this
cop should be honored he should have a
ticker tape parade
but because our culture is so stupid and
upside down at this point
he is
suspected of and being accused of
committing murder and
the the fact that he wasn't charged is
what's so shocking
it goes without saying i almost don't
want to say it that if the racial
uh roles were reversed this wouldn't
even be a news story but because we now
live in this culture that is obsessed
with race and this idea that white
people bad and black people good and all
black people are good and all white
people are bad and whiteness is the
cause of all evil in the world and
that's why we have to abolish it and
this is actually being taught in schools
and in board rooms and in the government
we are now shocked that this
violent criminal
after being shot by a cop after
resisting arrest is not going to see his
cop charged with murder speaking of
identity politics big big identity
politics story this is a story that the
daily wire broke i think we were the
first ones to this story just came out
last night and it's going to be
completely suppressed by the media it's
already being suppressed by the media so
pay attention
louden county
which has had a lot of problems in its
schools a lot of people protesting in
loudoun county because the schools are
covering up the radical
racial politics that are being taught
the radical gender sexual politics
they're being taught well it goes
further than just the curriculum
on june 22 scott smith was arrested at
loudoun county at a school board meeting
and the meeting was ultimately deemed an
unlawful assembly because
scott smith
who was a father in the district was
speaking out against a policy that lets
boys go into the women's bathroom and he
said that's all you saw that's all
people saw of the stories this guy this
crazy right-wing dad gets arrested at
the school board meeting because he is
anti-trans he's a transphobe and this is
mean and awful and bigoted
well what's the story
the
father
was the father of this young girl this
15 year old girl
who was raped
in a bathroom
at the school
by a boy
a boy who considers himself gender fluid
who sometimes wears a dress who went
into the school and allegedly raped the
girl
there is a lot of evidence for this the
daily wire investigative team did a very
good job parsing out this story
according to the father on may 28th a
boy wearing a skirt entered the girl's
bathroom at stone bridge high school and
sexually assaulted smith's ninth grade
daughter and
i don't want to go into the details too
much on this show but i know that the
term sexual assault is very broad these
days some people say sexual assault even
refers to if you just kiss somebody or
something like that
what this
boy who sometimes pretends to be a girl
is accused of doing to this ninth grade
girl is as bad as it gets
as vile as perverted as sick as violent
as it gets okay
and it's being covered up and the school
has denied it and then the evidence came
out that it actually happened and
they're still trying to deny it they're
trying to portray the father as the bad
guy here because why because they can't
admit that their policy is wrong
evil
false and puts the students in danger
and why because the experts have told us
that this can't happen if you let boys
and grown men i guess even go into the
girls bathroom nothing bad will happen
look these boys they're just they
actually they're girls secretly
sometimes they're not even girls all the
time they're just if they're fluid
they're just girls sometimes when they
feel like it and it's very wrong and
closed-minded of you to keep boys out of
the girl's room why of course the girls
room is for boys that's why it's called
the girls room if the girls if the boys
say that their girl's right that's what
the experts say
they say this can't happen the experts
furthermore say that this dad is a
domestic terrorist if you go in to a
school board and you question the racial
and gender radicalism going on at the
school boards well according to our
attorney general that makes you a
domestic terrorist
and yet
what does the investigation show
this dad is the most sane person in the
room you are the most sane person in the
room you assuming that you listening to
this
story right now are the sort of person
who thinks that actually boys should not
go into the girls bathroom that actually
boys cannot just become girls and
there's something a little wrong about
that
you are far from a domestic terrorist
you are the last sane person
one of the last same people in this
culture
and the experts are wrong and the
prevailing ideology is wrong and common
sense and prudence are right and the
ruling class wants to shut that up and
censor that and deny that and punish
people who think that as best they can
the greatest image to my mind
of the corruption of our regime and our
understanding of standards today
comes from rotten tomatoes
rotten tomatoes is the movie review
website
so rotten tomatoes
posted this movie that's about dr fauci
it's a geography of dr fauci it talks
about how wonderful he is it's on i
think what national geographic so the
movie comes out and for a long time you
can only see the reviewers the
professional critics reviews there's one
score for the professional critics and
then one score from the audience but the
audience score was grayed out you
couldn't see any of those and the
critics gave it a 91
so just finally yesterday after a lot of
pushback rotten tomatoes puts up the
audience scores you know what the
audience score was
four percent
ninety-one percent say the professional
critics the real elite smart genius
expert critics
four percent says the audience that's
the regime
that is the re the regime the dr fauci
hey geography our new ruler the most
exalted highest paid politician in the
country
the experts say
he's the greatest and the move the
hegeography of him is wonderful 91
but the people
disagree
that's
that's three you know that sometimes
you'll see a photo world war ii 1940
colorized you know that 1865 colorized
civil war photo this is the picture of
the american regime 2021 colorized
i've got some good news
from our
most exalted politician the esteemed
dr fauci peace be upon him
you remember dr fauci canceled christmas
uh he he was asked well he canceled
christmas last year then he was asked if
he was gonna cancel christmas this year
and this was just a week or two ago in
fact she said well it's too soon to tell
and then people pushed back against him
and he said look i never said you
couldn't have christmas i mean you did
you said it was too soon to tell so you
said there was a
good chance that we might not have
christmas then he said no maybe you i'll
have christmas it's fine so there is one
holiday that fauci likes
he says
you know putting christmas and
thanksgiving aside for now
at the very least you can celebrate
halloween
i think that particularly if you're
vaccinated but you can get out there
you're outdoors for the most part at
least when my children were out there
doing trick-or-treating
and enjoy it i mean this is a time that
children love it's it's a very important
part of the year for children i know my
children enjoyed it so i mean again
particularly if you're vaccinated if
you're not vaccinated again think about
it that you'll add an extra degree of
protection to yourself and your children
and your family and your community so
it's a good time to reflect on why it's
important to get vaccinated but go out
there and enjoy halloween as well as the
other holidays that will be coming up
so on the one hand i'm glad that fauci
is letting people have halloween that's
nice and especially little kids little
kids love halloween so much but there is
something funny to me that over the past
more than a year now and even in recent
weeks dr fauci
has said well maybe you can't have
christmas
you know the celebration of the nativity
of our lord and savior christmas yeah
maybe maybe not yeah
and thanksgiving i don't know about
thanksgiving you know when we give
thanks also to the lord our god for
giving us this beautiful country of ours
yeah maybe nah i don't know maybe yes
maybe no
oh but the one where you all dress up
like demons and go and play tricks on
people yeah do that one that one's good
we love that
okay the nativity of our lord no
thanksgiving no i don't think so but the
one where we talk about like devils and
witches and like throw eggs at each
other that one's totally fine that
doesn't spread coronavirus
but
thanksgiving
and midnight mass that does that does
spread coronavirus right
i'm being slightly unfair to dr fauci
here but not very unfair i think i
actually generally speaking i think i'm
being pretty pretty fair though i
actually i don't want to be
misunderstood i do like halloween
there's something very traditional and
cool and
medieval about going out and playing
tricks on each other and going door to
door asking for sweets and stuff and
dressing up so i i think it's it's great
i'm glad i just i'll take the win thank
you thank you dr fauci your your
eminence your
beneficence thank you so much for
allowing us to have our holiday at least
one of our holidays but don't get too
excited because fauci says that yeah
maybe you can go get some candy on
halloween but you might not be able to
get on an airplane pretty soon if you
don't take the fauci ouchie if you don't
take the experimental drug to protect
against the virus that poses a very very
low risk of hospitalization or death for
the vast majority of people
because while we might not have a
vaccine mandate on the planes
immediately
it it might happen
would you like a vaccine mandate for air
travel and effect for the holidays
well it depends on what you mean if
you're talking you know we do now have a
situation uh when people coming in from
outside of the country who are not
united states citizens they really must
require that they get vaccinated as well
as getting tested before what the
president has done regarding masks i
think is important namely doubling the
fine on people who refuse to wear masks
on on on airplanes on the table is the
issue of mandates for vaccine it's
always discussable we always wind up
discussing do you support it but right
now i don't see that immediately you
know dana i don't want to say support or
not i think it it it's a decision that's
made by input from a number of parts of
the government including public health i
mean obviously from a public health
standpoint the more protection you get
the better it is but i don't want to be
weighing in because we wind up then
having people taking things out of
context we have everything on the table
and it will be discussed by the medical
group
uh-huh so you support it is what you're
saying because what does he mean he goes
i don't want to give you an answer to
your direct question because then people
might take it out of context well then
give me the context or you can take it
out of context do you support a vaccine
mandate on an airplane well if i say yes
then people won't like me as much
yeah oh that's the context okay the
context is that you don't want to state
your honest opinion because you know
that you don't have the political
capital to enforce it yet but you might
in the future that's what this is really
about right fauci has done this many
many times
he obviously supports it and he admits
he goes from a public health standpoint
i want to muzzle up all you filthy
animals right
but i don't think i'm not going to say
it yet but soon enough we're going to do
it
that's what's going on here and it's
just an important reminder that well
the libs prattle on about the science
and the squishes think that the science
matters so they try to defend their
views and oppose the left's views with
the science actually it's not about the
science at all it's about politics and
it's about political power and right now
at least fouchy thinks he doesn't have
the political power
to
to do this but he very well
he very well might in the future
especially if we keep giving in which is
why it's important to resist these
things and you are seeing some good news
speaking of airlines you're seeing this
happen on southwest airlines right now
southwest airlines is mandating vaccines
for its staff
southwest airlines is cancelling lots
and lots of its flights it canceled a
thousand flights on sunday canceled
hundreds and hundreds if not a thousand
or more flights yesterday i didn't get
the final number it's canceling why is
that well they were blaming it on
weather it was a pretty sunshiny day on
sunday yesterday was pretty nice too it
wasn't because of the weather what's
really going on here is that the the
employees at southwest are having a sick
out they're not showing up for work
because they're not going to comply by
the way
this mandate is not even from the
government
osha the the agency that biden tasked
with enforcing the mandate hasn't even
put out its rules really yet
what what this did was this the
announcement from biden gave cover to
big corporations to mandate the vaccine
for the for the
employees
but it's not actually coming straight
from the government it's just now a
policy from the airlines and they can
pretend it was the government who made
them do it
so what the pilots and the staff members
are saying is okay you want to make me
do it fine go get another pilot go get
another staff member
go get another stewardess go get another
check in person
and i love it and by the way i've got to
take a lot of flights in the next few
days and i might have to miss some of my
flights and i hope i don't have to miss
some of these speaking events that i'm
going to but i love standing up because
what fauci knows what fauci knows what
the liberal ruling class knows is
this is a brute force battle of
political wills i mean all the way down
to when you question an election it's
evil and a threat to our democracy but
when we question an election as we have
for 20 years it's totally great and fine
and actually a defense of our democracy
right they just they know that it's
about wielding power here and so they're
gonna they're gonna creep up and creep
up gradually to wield power until they
get more and more and more of it and
what the southwest employees are saying
is no we're not going to do that totally
stand with them this is a really really
great move
if you don't stand up now
when are you going to do it i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show i will
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there